hello my beautiful sluggies it has been
so amazing to perform for you i can't
wait to see more of you and meet more of
you please come see me at mil the
milwaukee improv this coming weekend you
can then see me at
uh the zany's in chicago on september
7th and 8th you can see me
at cleveland hilarity's september 9th
through 11th then i'll be at
riley rayleigh north carolina at good
night september 23rd to through 25th
come teach me how to say it um i'm also
going to be at the
fest at a festival in vegas that i can't
remember the name of it but billy also
is going to be there but it's life is
beautiful festival uh on the six
18th and 19th
that was sloppy and also the wig will be
explained
hi slugs what a crazy episode this is
about to be like i'm so
scared for what didn't get edited out if
it's not if this episode is more than
five minutes i'm
um you guys i'm coming on tour this fall
i have all my dates in one place
esteronice.com which apparently means
i'm on meth and everyone no one told me
i just thought it was funny because
disney on ice estheronics.com florida
my brain goes to you being a corpse
honestly
oh
but no one else's brain goes to like ice
skating shows no esther we're grown-ups
we're grown people today's episode is a
mess
no today's episode was absolutely
beautiful sleepover by esther.com for
wonderful
handmade garments
i'll see you in hell and mine were
really messy so i'm gonna say also go to
andyletterman.com for the tour dates and
also this wig is a precursor to one a
great episode and two
a calendar i'm coming out with that's
gonna be really awesome you can find all
my merch at annie letterman.com too
[Music]
goth to me i i don't like to me you guys
are more like we're like wiccan
to me because crossover
you cross over you read emo
you read emo which is sort of like baby
goth you look like regular like you
could just wear this it works it's fine
no
i feel like i went for like high school
girl golf yeah cause that's what i know
that's what i think of when i think of
gotham like high school girls but your
high school girl gots were probably like
in theater with you no like they were
able to take the makeup off no no no
that's all wrong
okay
they went hard
now kalila you thought glowing on your
top lashes was hard try going on the
bottom [ __ ] holy [ __ ] wait what
i went i honestly asked her i thought i
was going to look like second i thought
you were going to come in like trisha
paytas well also i got added to this
episode late like because i remember
this was supposed to be a guest
right how funny is it to put it make a
guest be god
this is for something you know what i
think you're guessing
we almost had chris stefano
wait annie i want to know about these
contacts what country did you order them
from i am assuming china with how no
offense uh with how chintzy they were
and that's not a china attack it's
that's when you make the cheapest
products okay that's why you have so
much money in power but um jules was
trying to show me how to put contacts in
and i was like jules your contacts are
like real context these are like paper
thin they've fallen in the toilet
several times like both of them wanted
to just match wait one of those was in
the toilet and then went to your eye it
was worse than in the toilet it was on
the toilet
oh that is worse
in the toilet there's some water washing
it around my heart i think in the toilet
would be worse
if you're in my house because that's
where you were born that's where you
were delivered
oh i missed you guys i feel like i
haven't seen you in so long i love you
this is this munchkin head doing i i
want this hair color so bad it reminds
me of ozzy osbourne when on the
osborne's ozzy had like just the bottom
half of his hair dyed a collar like that
and i've always wanted i don't want to
say i was going for i was born um but
i'll take it
um it's coming from forever dave grohl i
told you did i tell him this when i was
trying to get a picture of dave girl for
you and whitney was like get away from
him you like want to be nowhere you're
like i don't even care about dave girl
this is like this is literally for
esther i was going to tag her what's a
celebrity where um who you absolutely
needed to get a photo with and broke
your own rules of it was jeff probst
i've been through this so much it's so
it's so much more embarrassing than
what about you esther has there you know
in l.a we were never supposed to take
pictures with anyone right well there
was a story when annie i made annie get
the photo for me we're at lax and we saw
jordan woods who's kylie jenner's best
friend and this was like the height of
kylie in the height of jordan woods and
i was like annie i think that's jordan
woods like but i ca i can't and if it's
for someone else i'm surely willing to
i'm like i can't do it i can't do it and
she's like what okay who where and she
and i had no clue she was too you're
like and i i think i told you go say are
you kylie's best friend and you did and
she's like yeah and then i got my
picture you got your picture you didn't
like the picture enough to post it
because i was like when the drama came
out i was like you should post team
jordan i was not are you not team jordan
no i don't have teams for the
kardashians stuff i'm just not that
invested we're team skims i buy the
products we're not invested as in we're
not investing in this company we're
spending so much money on which we
probably should try to yeah financially
invested not emotionally what i feel
like i have a million questions how was
new york
it was really fun
but i'm so glad i don't live there guys
living in new york what are you doing
why are you why are you suffering what's
going on what's the suffering part it's
everything it's it's the swamp ass like
when you're in la you can you can i feel
like you mentioned swamp ass everywhere
you go you have that like i feel like
that you win okay but i'll say okay
austin there were swamp s2 well because
we live in a nice dry heat i don't feel
oh i hate this dry heat i hate it i
prefer small baths well wait until
you're back in it oh i grew up in the
philippines so it's familiar to me and
my skin my eczema flares up in dry
weather i look so beautiful and in
humid weather too i'm so pretty human
weather humans never seen you know
never seen yet
wait chicago is what if you are the
alien on earth what if you were the one
that's been here the whole time
and then your hair is beautiful in humid
weather for you to accuse me of being
the alien while your eyes look like that
is actually would the alien dress up
like that as goth or this the alien
would be hiding in plain sight
wait you know what i was thinking i was
thinking about how you asked me why i
keep calling you short out of nowhere
yeah that's because we were on facetime
and i wasn't seeing you in person
that's funny
you're i wish you could experience what
it's like to be a person seeing feet
dangle it's like it's the most it takes
you see that's a really good answer it
took me a while because i was like no
because i always make fun of you for
being short your name is little esther
i i don't think there's any been there's
i have the hits i have the hits that i
make people there's something here if
there's black on my teeth at any point
point
let me know listen if there's an eyelash
falling into my nipple hair at any point
please let me know i want to talk about
this um
i don't like your tone we have i don't
like your tone
it it it involves your lower lash line
um we cry about it we cry about having
to put on lashes we're so bad at it how
bad we must communicate in
trouble everyone must have this trouble
and then annie sends me a video of a guy
named gabe wheatley who has no limbs who
puts on me yes no not only does he have
no fingers there's no arms and he's able
to crush putting on lashes
guys i'm here to tell you it's how
does he use his feet no he has he's not
feet either he has he sets it up in his
neck
and then he puts it he'll like put it
with his mouth i'll put the glue on find
the video yeah so annie basically sent
me this video and she was like no excuse
but we are so full so we're back to
lashes the lashes are back on
he's amazing they're just all trash this
is really mesmerizing oh my god no
there's a guy listen i'm so into people
that are like if you notice people that
are born with like a disability or
something
that you would call missing they're
always end up being better at things
well it's because they learn how to
compensate like
yeah right they can it's all like people
who have no arms if they have they use
their feet to do look at this [ __ ] oh my
god these foot fetish people are piping
up the glasses look at those lashes
perfection that's so beautiful the
rhinestone eye oh my god he's a king
he's something scissors we're useless
anyway everything hurts it's just i'm
wearing toilet contacts
i'm very concerned
you know it you know it's funny so the
traffic again was like a nightmare but i
was like i can't like road rage in black
lipstick like i can't like
i can't so i just wasn't at peace with
it we had a godfrey on yesterday on
tiger valley and he said it's you should
we should read gilbert or godfrey
not without the gilbert
and he said that road rage is not real
rage it's passion for driving oh that's
so funny that's convenient
it's like if you have a real passion for
like the technicality of driving that's
where the frustration is it's the most
okay that's so not true because i've
never been good at driving and i've had
road rage but it's like i think it's a
control issue and it's like what i
always try to look at is like why am i
like expecting other people to drive
away like they're just doing their
things nothing to do with me yeah but it
is i think people save up all of their
rage through life yes and then they wait
for this moment where no one
yes like i would love to hear you just
slurring away in your i've never had a
yelling i've never had a road rage but
wouldn't it be just so fun if that was
your little secret just your little
heads popping up
like that's not what gets my
what do you rage out over i i don't i'm
not rage she doesn't have right i don't
think i have rage
you've got to get widow's the most
pissed off you've ever been where you've
yelled the top of your lungs
i don't i um i need to think
but i i do not to deflect but i do want
to say that
living in l.a has made me hate driving
and i didn't realize it's just la
driving
until i i have to drive now like an hour
away for work
join the club [ __ ] but like i thought i
would hate it and because it's not a
traffic drive
i'm like
it's so much fun i'm blessed to buy
music i'm free i'm by myself right i
stop at my starbucks drive through like
i am living life you need to go on a
road trip by yourself you'll like it
it's actually my favorite thing to do
it's so fun you've done that yes i used
to love to drive from santa fe to l.a
latest tell me about it i wanna somehow
i think that you on a road trip alone is
safe and esther is not i feel like
someone would just like take you you
gotta get back from the books to sit on
uh little extenders little put some tuna
cans together in the bottom of the feet
so she could touch but what did you like
stop and get like drive-through fast
food yes well i do have a rule that um
i'm allowed one a free lapse for me so
when you're in uh when you're sober
you're
which i i don't even claim to be anymore
i don't drink but
anyway
sorry enough oh my god speaking of sober
i have a huge thing to announce but
did you quit the alcohol you never drank
no no
this is like when my mom quit drinking
the same time i did she was like oh it's
been so hard quitting i go what
she goes yeah it's been hard to go mom
what did you quit drinking too she goes
i quit right after you did and i'm like
when did you drink
i was stealing my sober thunder
free laps oh my free laps is always i
can snort adderall at uh
taco bells on my drives
that's in barcelona no wonder you love
road trips
that sounds amazing somehow honestly
that sounds like the most relatable
thing you've ever said thank you so much
because i think that i have not snorted
it but definitely [ __ ] with ritalin in
barstow
um at a del taco on my way to vegas you
get it [ __ ] you get it that's all about
the open road in the desert yeah it
makes sense to me
it's an underrated but highly relatable
statement i think that on the surface it
may not look seem like something people
would do but it is now i have i will
tell you the truth i have retired
snorting addraw at this point because
it does nothing it doesn't help in any
way i realized it was just me again
chasing being bad you know what i used
to do when i said okay no more ritalin
um i got really hooked on something
that's not even supposed to be addictive
but it's this
thing that herbalife and neutral life
cells it's called rhodiola
and i used to just take paxo rhodiola
and it's supposed to be like good for
you you just get on that [ __ ] not
only does it road it gives you diarrhea
so i felt skinny and then it gives you
like a it feels like coffee if diarrhea
still at this point made me feel skinny
i mean it's been so many years since
diary has made me feel skinny
i learned it'll hang there it'll hang on
the bloat will happen
the bloat is gas um
does snorting adderall
make a difference in any way yeah no no
no it just what it was just like fun i
just was like i miss being bad and i
will say this even though i have retired
the snorting of anything
don't recommend it
um
i did go and i got a cup of coffee and
then and the straw they used was so cute
that i said
maybe i'll just do one more blue rail
homework done it was so cute i was like
i would love to snort something because
this straw was cute it was so cute
esther this story is not happening
nobody thought you were gonna
relate to this
nobody you just said you had realized
you had fun driving for the fourth time
you're in your early to mid-thirties
what is the blue line why'd you call it
blue because the adderall i would would
be a five milligrams you know how george
got buru dangad in colombia and it's
that drug where you seem like you're
acting normally but you're actually
being you're you're
[ __ ] up what's cool is like george was
like as george was like blowing this guy
he was like really into it and he was
like
but i wonder i wonder if we all
got each other and then just did did an
episode i wonder if oh no we would have
control of what we were saying and what
would actually if we drug ourselves we
should try things that are not like
crazy for you i mean i know that you've
dabbled in dayquil
look at how hard you're laughing
because you're pathetic
how are we friends it's really weird
i've literally
by the time i was your height i'd
already done all these it's weird i
always forget it too it's like i was so
sincere when i brought up dave quill and
you guys just [ __ ] bulldozed me i was
what did you want to throw you a party
oh my god her gateway drug she's gonna
be on [ __ ]
tylenol pm in no time
do you guys know you know z-quill
oh she knows the variations but no this
is really important this is like i'm
about to blow your mind
i thought you were going to blow me
do you know z-quilt where it's like okay
it's literally the same exact thing as
benadryl it's the same drug they just
market it as equal and benadryl is so
much [ __ ] cheaper and it's the same
thing
there yeah it's diphenhydramine yes did
you know this coloco yeah i like that
you're like well you didn't tell us you
just like taking them down but what if
you take them down and then you can't
have your sweet sweet dayquil anymore no
what drug are you going to do
amazon brand day quill is cheaper anyway
i want to take you to the amazon and
give you something
i want to i want to i want to shoot at
you with a dart and have you ever
poisoned hallelujah
poison dart frog they're very cute but
they're very very toxic esther they'd
kill us all
frogs huge i drew them in
yeah don't get too excited baby's
learning
you look like babies learning mommy well
someone was scrapped i look like the
crap yeah oh thank you i think that was
what i was going for you look more like
a like like i do arts and crafts
okay this is actually crazy did you guys
know do you know why free trials renew
without your consent so they can get
away with it it's literally a business
scam out to get you and there's one way
like to finally stop that and it's true
bill trubill is this new app that helps
you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need or
want or that you just like forgot about
and on average people actually save up
to 720 a year with drew bill because
companies will make subscriptions hard
to cancel we've all had that right like
where you're like
it's supposed to cancel they literally
make it impossible if you go to their
site the cancel button is the hardest
thing to find no i go to use my credit
card they're like you're overdrawn i'm
like what are you talking about i look
it's like oh i've been spending seven
thousand dollars a month on it's shady
it's shady but they're they [ __ ] do
it
um but because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel true bill
makes it incredibly simple just link
your accounts and trouba will cancel
your unwanted subscriptions in one tap
and your true bill concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to don't
fall for a subscription scam start
cancelling today at truebill.com trash
tuesday you guys go right now
trash tuesday it could save you i'm not
kidding thousands a year truebill.com
trash tuesday you know the dirty little
not so secret about the bedding aisle is
that while cotton might be the most
popular fabric for sheets duvets and
pillowcases it's actually also the most
damaging to our planet and that's why we
are so thrilled to introduce you to
etitude by using 100 organic bamboo
fabric attitude sheets say 500 times
more water than cotton and produce 52
percent less carbon emissions so they're
comfortable for you and the environment
i love my attitude sheets i think that
they are the softest most highest
quality sheets i've ever used you know
what i love about the most the coolness
i'm i run hot when i sleep so these um
these sheets just really really allow my
body to breathe in the middle of the
night uh every spot is the wet spot in
my bed that's why i need these sheets
you guys know i'm a lazy girl and i love
to lay down i have tried all of the like
bedding that you've heard about and read
about this i'm not kidding you attitude
is my by far my favorite one i recommend
it to all my friends and you can try it
for 30 days and you're not if you're not
completely satisfied you can return it
for a full refund right now you can get
20 off your order plus free shipping
when you visit attitude headed
attitude.com tuesday and enter promo
code tuesday remember that's attitude as
in eco attitude order today for free
shipping and 20 off your order at
editude.com
tuesday that's e-t-t-i-t-u-d-e
dot com slash tuesday promo code tuesday
there's this beauty vlogger
who and you know beauty vloggers like on
youtube they get so famous and they get
so much and the beauty community is like
extremely
they're they're very woke community way
more so than i would say comedy and i
remember when she said something that i
always think about when people don't
like me online and she said thank god
for that unsubscribe button
and so like i always say that to myself
like when i'm like thank god that you're
you can unsubscribe you can unfollow
thank god for that what a concept like
you are so let like go
yeah if you're mad that what if for
whatever reason well it's always just
like a control thing and trying to like
tell people it's just like what what's
the point of being alone
i didn't get a platform because i follow
everyone else's like
i'm not i'm not even an actress like i
am a comedian i say my own words and i
think this actually applies to like my
experience as being like asian american
but not asian
not asian american the same way that
other people are asian-american it's
like i'm a 1.5 i grew up in asia my
sensibilities are different than someone
who was born and raised here and what
they what they feel they need to
gatekeep in terms of their asian-ness
the culture i don't feel like i need to
gatekeep because it's like i grew up in
a culture that was like here we share it
you want to wear a kimono on saya
akimona and saya wear it you wanna dance
the nickling do it
but that might not be the same for a
filipino born and raised here where
they're like no my you know my culture
is not your costume or they have a
completely different set of ideas than
me because they're seeing it through
their upbringing here but i don't feel
the need to ever like gatekeep my
asian-ness and i yeah i think i do get
in trouble
there's a there's a rift there and i
feel very disconnected to
some asian americans in that way
people that you're resonating with that
feel exactly like you it's this it's
just it's like if you say what you
believe right like and you are true to
like what you think is like right for
you yeah that's literally the only thing
you can do because what's the point of
[ __ ] anything
right and it's it's this it's like when
when there was a group of filipinos
scholarly filipinos say for instance or
i'm sorry um filipino americans who were
like oh let's add the x at the end of
filipino or filipino let's do philippine
x
i have trans friends at home in the
philippines that i grew up with who are
like wait a second we don't have
pronouns in our language you americans
don't get
to tell us what we're supposed
to call ourselves
but in the meantime there are people
that do subscribe to it and some people
that don't so there's sort of this like
back and forth about it but it's like
ultimately
no one is correct and no one is wrong
because we're all
speaking from our own lived experiences
yeah and our lens and like what we value
it's like all your values and i think
it's just like i just it's like
controversial but i'll say it being that
you know i grew up in asia
but
it's like
say for instance the olly london thing
that kid who wanted to be
he was white who said he's considered
racial does it feel [ __ ] weird for me
to see that yeah it feels icky
but
at the same time do i know that korea is
the number one leading country in
cosmetics to alter their eyes to be to
look more westernized and white yeah
they are just like yeah i just feel like
i don't want to tell like whether i
don't want to say like to like kim
kardashian don't get your ass done like
i'm a hippie i would like in in my
perfect world in my life i have no botox
i have no nothing i like to be like to
get as good with myself and my body as i
can possibly be if someone else wants to
transition into another
sex right that is so i so support
whatever their [ __ ] journey is and i
believe that whatever they want and
they're gonna handle this it's not my
business it's not my business i don't
stand up for anyone to say anything like
i live my life to be kind to everyone
and give everyone grace that's literally
it but it's like someone who's gonna
come for you for saying that you know as
for saying something like that it's like
people don't stop and take a look at the
fact that this kid ollie london looks
like he's mentally ill yeah and that's
that that's ultimately what we were
saying and i think that yeah you don't
have to give him that he's great you
don't go like all right you're korean
and now you like but you didn't have any
of the struggles it's just like
there's so many different esther and i
are friends and her big drug was dayquil
okay like
do you know what i mean it's like i was
doing [ __ ] crazy drugs when i was 13.
it's like you can you can have different
experiences and still like appreciate
the other person's life and by the way
for the record i'm not saying that my
feelings are correct they're just my
feelings from my own lived experiences i
will not gatekeep anything
filipino she won't gabe keep either i
mean she's really just let it out let's
be honest she's let a lot of people have
it if someone says something extremely
offensive towards jewish people towards
women something you know i'm right here
like i
i want to approach them with
love and like i want to help them
understand my side from a positive place
and not be like you're [ __ ] sexist
like you know i don't want to be angry
if i'm passionate about something
because
this is
the opposite like the anger and the rage
yeah it makes me really uncomfortable it
is a very american thing it's not real
it's someone like literally going
through their day trying to have a thing
to make them feel like they're like
gotcha and then i'm gonna do this like
it's the same as the blood bath girls we
can't like look at what they're doing
what what they all want is our attention
and us talking about them so the blood
death girls are now trying i don't know
what they're trying to do to me or
whatever i'm never watching it i don't
care
anyone that watches whatever their
[ __ ] [ __ ] video is and
and agrees with them please oh unfollow
everything i've ever done get the [ __ ]
away from me i literally am here to
[ __ ] get over myself be good make
people feel good make people laugh if
you don't want to get on board with that
get the [ __ ] away from me like i will
not be controlled i never have been i
never will be it's like [ __ ] off by the
way the best point ever made was about
the name bloodbath when it's friends
making fun of each other and it's a
little bit of a period joke is cute
bloodbath when it's about the victims of
a [ __ ] crime it's absolutely
disgusting that's really real and to say
one of the comments they said about us
was like serial killers are better than
us we're worse than serial killers
because we don't apologize to the
victims by the way there's nothing to
apologize to and the serial killers are
not okay they're never okay you are
misogynists you're misogynist you hate
women you pray and you try to make money
off of the death of innocent [ __ ]
women so how about that how about that
do you want us to [ __ ] release that
[ __ ] yeah do you want people to know
that about you drop that [ __ ] around
we're showing girls that they can be
themselves get over their [ __ ] trauma
love each other be supportive and speak
their own [ __ ] mind in a world where
men tell us what to [ __ ] say all the
time and we have to conform we don't
[ __ ] do that we talk about diarrhea
period
and we [ __ ] eat gross [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] you like during and we're like
we're horrible we both we never bullied
you once we took the name down we just
were trying to be nice to you and you
wanted more you wanted merch money you
wanted attention all you want is money
clout and to look like victims well
you're not [ __ ] victims but you know
who are the girls you exploit for your
[ __ ] show that has 40 followers so
enjoy your shitty little career
and you'll never get a hundred thousand
[ __ ] dollars from us if you would ask
for ten by the way you might have gotten
yeah
mama has spoken it's like enough like
what what do we want our followers to do
not be themselves and scared and and
victims of their we were all [ __ ]
molested in every hole except esther but
her time will come
maybe during this episode i had some
things yeah you did a couple things
that's true
for some reason she hides them
i think that you hit the nail on the
head and i think that ultimately
we've not called it what it was which
has
they've been bullied you're you're
bullying us you're trying to extort us
we know our power and that's why we
don't talk about you because you will be
destroyed by our fans we don't want them
to feel bad we don't want them to go
against you we want to just move on with
the shittiest name ever kalyana picked
it i did i didn't enjoy it george
george does coke though so we'll give
him a pass he's a drug
addict and he's drugged do you guys want
to hear two girls talk about the same
murders you heard everyone else talk
about yeah who are calling us bullies
out of nowhere that we've literally been
protecting for months and months and
months do you hate our new name so do we
everyone [ __ ] does we loved our name
it made sense we could have coexisted
with them we actually were going to have
them be our true crime correspondents
but they went around and told everyone
we were thieves and liars and said we
were doing things we never did they are
unsafe i don't negotiate with terrorists
yes so go watch their show if you like
it and resonate with it please give them
your money
please they please it seems like they
really want to build an empire go follow
them do whatever do it do it do it on
the charities
because even after we changed the name
they still took it down vengefully they
they literally gave us more [ __ ] even
after we changed the name after we
changed the name and it's like i don't
even want to be mad because i shouldn't
let anyone make me mad but it's like
it's so [ __ ] frustrating we're biting
our tongues trying to help and protect
them and they can't stop and we've been
harassed and bullied harassed and
bullied everything they wanted a private
apology from esther because they made up
a situation in their head where they
thought esther was speaking directly to
them you feel that's like stopping your
stuff someone out there thinks you're
speaking to them that like is what made
me feel unsafe
something in your head that i'm i'm
threatening you or i think the line that
they were upset about was like
like one of our first podcasts which we
filmed months before we even they even
acknowledged us
was you said um like where's the
bloodbath girls let it be known like and
and they let the core it's been a
bloodbath let the courts
he's gonna sue me all the time because
i'm gonna kill her because it's
bloodbath because we're friends that
[ __ ] with each other do you understand
it has nothing to do with you listen
angels go for your life get over
yourselves your life will be better okay
i work on this myself too okay i'm not
saying i'm perfect and i want i want you
to be successful and but your mindset is
not correct okay your mindset is
paranoid and it's not it is not
it's not where we're coming from and you
want an apology i'm sorry i'll say i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm apologizing
for but i'm sorry no i'm getting
emotional because i do feel like i i i
think that anyone can relate to this
like there's something in your life that
you have to just keep a smile on your
face and you can't let people know
what's going on behind the scenes but
like since the day we started this
podcast this has been going on and we
never talk about it because like like
what women usually do we just put a
smile on our faces and like keep it
going and i'm i'm just there's something
emotionally cathartic i think that what
it is esther is that we genuinely don't
want to hurt anyone even like this is a
comedy show yeah like we've never set
out to hurt anyone's feelings step on
anyone's toes this was our whole our
home project between three friends we
came up with a name from the english
dictionary that we liked that was once a
movie
that was based on a band that is like
you know and and what we set out to do
was just something light and funny and
really positive and what has transpired
and helping women helping such a bummer
and the fact that we've had to just take
the high road and play nice
and pretend like nothing's happening is
you're right it's it's it's been a
[ __ ] frustrating process and did i
not do we not have a conversation was
like you know what we should just do a
thing and try to be as nice as possible
and every time we're about to do that
they send another threatening [ __ ]
email some threat about something or
we've done this or we changed the name
on purpose like
stop watching true crime stop it
you're paranoid stop we'll wait out got
a puppy
got a puppy go look at the trees it's
beautiful out it's beautiful out what
about the weeks or months that like
after we changed the name because we
were being threatened like all a lot of
our listeners were upset and they they
were like oh i don't want to listen
anymore because you changed your name
and we're just sitting here like we
didn't want to change our name like we
were being harassed and by the way i
couldn't tell anyone
there was no taking of a name we didn't
know who you were literally
you literally have a i'm not even trying
to be rude you have a small following
it's very very small it's very small you
know what we're doing we're actually
business women that are getting together
to write due to a podcast that resonates
with young girls that makes them happy
do you know what happens when i do my
shows now my live shows girls come up
crying that they feel so much better
about being molested and what's happened
to them because we talk openly about it
so keep shutting us down we're so mean
to women we're so mean to them and then
go oh is there another girl that got
murdered innocently that you want to
bathe in their blood
like what are you talking about and did
we ever once say we don't want you to
have the name do we ever care did it
have anything to do we didn't know you
existed until we already had launched
and filmed the first few episodes so
sorry we came up with the name before
you existed i don't know what you're
talking about there's no thievery no
one's taking from you and it didn't take
anything from you all it did was get you
more attention yeah and honestly we're
happy to share that attention yeah it's
like look like
whatever trickle-down
followers that you get out of this
happy to have you see how happy to see
you have them we were gonna have you be
correspondents but we you know who we
don't have people that call us liars and
thieves and make up stories about us and
bully us that's who we don't have yeah
i'm sorry this has been honestly my
favorite episode
because and i and i really apologize for
like my i shouldn't be this heated
because i don't
anger's not the thing it's just it's
exactly what esther's saying it's like
we've been holding it yeah yeah
and like i literally i'm like on the
verge of tears like since you started
talking about the asian stuff like i'm
just so
it's such a shitty feeling to like hold
something in and be be harassed and be
scared and like i don't know it's just
and be told you're bad when your
intentions were never like never bad at
all right i don't even know what to say
like i don't i don't know what to say
i'm just like glad we're talking about
this it's like therapeutic because this
has just been really shitty and i'm
grateful that we have the show and that
we [ __ ] are we're a huge success yeah
and guess what success we are we're huge
no matter no matter what you're in [ __ ]
star she's the only one that exercises
whether worf whether this is blood bath
trash tuesday slug town annie esther
kalila show it's whatever we imbue it
with right it's like our followers our
fans we love them so dearly they've
latched we've latched back it's like
this
mutualistic love and no matter what we
are no matter what name we have we're
going to do well it also doesn't matter
it's like you can have the name we don't
care we've been stop harassing us guys
it's like we've given you a b c d and e
everything just
leave us the [ __ ] along you got our
itunes taken down that's more people
that could have been inspired and felt
good about themselves that can't have
that now so also when there was a third
podcast bloodbath
like they bully the [ __ ] out of those
they did
and it's like dude like it's just how
many bad friends are there there's like
five yeah yeah how many like hey baby
this exists i used to do a thing called
sausage party presents with me and my
friend abby it was called sausage party
it was we would take hot dogs and we
would recreate scenes with it and we
would make original content and then i
saw my friend caperland on the subway
she was oh my god congrats on the movie
i go what are you what are you talking
about she goes oh you're doing that
movie with seth seth
rogen sausage party and i went
nope that's unfortunate oh well you move
on you make something new you keep
moving forward nothing about our show
gets in the way of your show in any way
yeah i think that if you spent all of
this energy and legal fees into actually
creating legitimate content
you would build an empire but if you're
continually continually obsessing and
using that energy to go after girls that
are just trying to do a home project
um
it's gonna
it's
it's gonna backfire
how many alone togethers were there in
the world
a lot well look it became like the
slogan for covid19 yeah look at that
coven stone and there was another one
you should still call it coveto's esther
an apology clove has been looking you
through the camera and yelling at you
yeah it's just so it's this is a it was
a it's been a really weird situation
that i just didn't see coming for myself
or for us what i found the funniest
though is they really had it up for you
poor little babies i mean that made me
feel scared like i
you know i've had stalkers and stuff
like i
they're again i'm right here
there's protocol for that like yeah i
you know
had to do some things to make sure you
know i i just don't know who these
people are when they start talking to
you like they know you i don't know it's
just this whole thing is it's really
shitty and i feel like people
all all day every day there are people
out there in their own workplaces where
they have to grin and smile through
something where they're being harassed
or like threatened
um and it just is so shitty and i wish
there was something that we could do and
maybe even just sharing about it is
helpful but it's i don't know it's just
it's like i just feel really emotional
like i can't articulate and yeah i don't
know like i just am so grateful that
annie is here to like
be our mouthpiece yeah
like say what i think we've all been
feeling and afraid to say all of this to
say by the way
stop complaining about the name change
we're going to change it into something
else we're like an art exhibit every two
months trash tuesday
maybe we should just keep it honestly
maybe we should just keep it the name
doesn't matter you guys are what matters
the three of us i look my i wanted to
pitch to take the h out and just be
blood bats
that's great we should do bad baths
bleed baths i want slug bath slug bath
oh yeah slug bath slug bath is cute
even bath girls i know i [ __ ] all over
esther and her mother
and now i didn't know she's been being
harassed online i want to get on track
but i'm also glad we feel so how about
this we hop off the horse and we switch
gears
do you guys feel like you have a cabinet
full of acne treatments and skincare
products but you literally don't
remember what half of them do because
they don't work yeah and it's so hard to
navigate through skincare products
because there are so many things
marketed out there and you just don't
really know what i wish i had someone to
just guide me girl
that's where apostrophe comes in okay
because apostrophe is a prescription
skincare company that offers
science-backed oral and topical
medications that are clinically proven
to help clear acne now i've given signs
back to oral myself but
no i after this makeup i need apostrophe
i mean this i'm going to be breaking out
so hard so
i'm so excited i have it at my house
right now apostrophe connects you with a
board-certified dermatologist who will
create a personalized treatment plan
that is perfectly tailored to your
unique skin simply fill out apostrophe's
online quiz about your skin goals and
medical history then snap a few selfies
and your dermatologist will create your
customized treatment plan apostrophe
treats acne and they can also help you
hit your other skincare goals like
reducing redness which is one of mine
wrinkles and even dark spots i have to
say like i have done such a deep dive
into the skincare world and you can get
lost so easily and to just have one
trusted place that is science-backed is
so important if you actually want to
target your issues exactly because not
all products are for everybody for
instance like i i have eczema so my skin
is very very sensitive so i like the
fact that someone can then tell me hey
maybe retinol or things with like
vitamin c
aren't the best for you maybe less is
more try this botanical oil try this or
try this acne thing or try this for your
eczema i just need to be told so i don't
go experimenting and [ __ ] up my skin
all the more you're messing up money too
it's like you waste so much money and
then it's like you really do just have
bins in your i mean yeah every time i
move i'm throwing out so many products
and you can't like share skin products
no and by the way you say you want to be
told but it's like you can't just walk
into like you know any old store and
have the person there you want that's
why apostrophe is so good you're told by
a freaking doctor a dermatologist yeah
we have a special deal for our audience
and you can save 15 off your first visit
with a board certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
tuesday when you use our code tuesday
and this code is only available to our
listeners and to get started just go to
apostrophe.com tuesday and click begin
visit then use our code tuesday at sign
up and you'll get 15 off your
dermatology visit that's apost
dot com slash tuesday and use the code
tuesday to get your dermatology visit
and save 15
and we thank apostrophe for sponsoring
this podcast is it still summer
because there are a lot of tents being
pitched in my household
that's right
this episode was sponsored by blue chew
you guys confidence can take you far in
life and it can also help you in the
bedroom especially when it comes time to
step up to the plate that's where blue
chew comes in blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
any time day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises the process is super
simple you sign up at blueshoe.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so there's no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy and blue chews tablets are
made in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package
they always say first impressions are
important
but on this podcast
we say what about lasting impressions
i have to say that there's nothing
sexier than confidence and blue chew can
help give you confidence where it counts
if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a very
special deal for our listeners try blue
chew free when you use our promo code
tuesday at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluetrue.com
promo code tuesday to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast ladies bluechu is exclusively
for men but the end result is something
you'll both enjoy so get your man to
sign up
[Music]
i have special goth food guys we'll let
esther open it and see what it is and
then everybody else gets to eat it what
is a god i'm targeted esther you need to
accept if it's like a bag
you have to accept responsibility for
what you are
which is what a walking tiny little star
your reaction looking at it will be more
than their reaction eating it so that's
why it's fun
oh i'm really scared i'm really i'm now
i just don't drop it i'm about to eat it
i'm not scared it's not going to attack
me oh my god oh my god that's really bad
you guys that's really bad
horrible really bad all right hold on
you're actually that's literally like
worst nightmare example that like no one
would ever do
but like i'm in shock
here's what i have to say you know what
i'm not is i'm not hungry for my banana
anymore that's a [ __ ] tarantula
[Applause]
oh it's kind of cute too why is it so
okay wait i'm gonna have to eat this i
might have to call joe
i'm gonna call joe rogan i think i have
to leave the room
it's not
alive it's a tarantula it's not live i
had two tarantulas one named boris and
one named charlie they're very sweet oh
my god i'm gonna see if rogan will coach
me through this i don't this can't
happen anymore
this is it's gotta keep do you
understand that is why it has to keep
happening
no
no annie no
they do worse on the challenge oh my god
she's doing it oh my gosh she's doing it
i don't really like i don't want to
touch it oh my god i'm not like
interested in yeah and he's punk
oh it's crunchy
it's not chocolate
is that
nothing chocolate about it
what
you lighter i'm like just dry i'm
gagging just a dried tarantula
i just gagged she's throwing up in her
lady gaga shirt
please throw up we need the views
again it's like there's no taste
there's nothing tarantula about it it's
just something about like theories of
chocolate
and then after you bit into it he told
you it wasn't chocolate is like making
me really sick
do you know what's kind of sicker you
know it's kind of sicker esther what
the kalila like these were her pets this
is like if we ate our dogs
like kalila you sick [ __ ] these were
your pets i used to feed them crickets
you want to know their names were boris
and charlie
i have pictures i'll send you guys pics
but it's like sister needs a pic i am
can i just apologize for laughing so
hard to the audio listeners uh seeing
esther be the only one who did not eat
that and react the most
is kind of hilarious oh that's smart
annie give me some of your banana to
chase it
oh
like are you gonna go home and like kiss
todd with that mother here i got my own
annie i'm gonna suck his dick i was
literally so hungry and so excited when
i got my banana and now i i
thought i cannot believe the
transformation of you and bananas
i've worked through my anger and now i'm
just proud of you i feel like it's your
favorite fruit now i i like it but i
don't i'm so hungry right now and
watching you bite into the dried
non-covered tarantula like i just am so
scarred
how do you feel
i feel great but i'm having a
breakthrough with you because
i feel like it was annoying me when you
were like adapting and getting better at
things
a little bit because i was like why was
she like
so difficult about it before if she
could eventually eat a banana but i
actually am [ __ ] proud of you you're
actually breaking down boundaries
you're getting better you guys the new
and improved esther 2.0 also i wanted to
watch her now
i want to walk through the psychological
um terror that you're feeling um
how what are your thoughts on eating
crab or lobster or shrimp
is it repulsive to you yeah when you see
people eat it or when you see it on a
table just lobster meat
i'm just not i'm not
i'm not repulsed but i'm just like i
don't want that because i'm not repulsed
because my fiance yeah dave likes
scrabble he loves that right so
essentially all dave is doing is eating
sea spiders that's exactly it they have
an exoskeleton they are the same family
we actually call them bugs like when we
go lobstering we get we call lobsters
bugs because they're
you're not helping her they're insects
they're water insects but certainly you
must know that like people it's a very
common fear to be afraid of spiders i'm
not letting you yeah but it's a it's
it's dead that's like the famous
argument oh if you see a spider it's
good because they're eating the bugs but
i don't mind the bugs
it's the spiders okay bring her bugs
next
no no no
if i brought no i wouldn't do this
because i don't want to terrorize
support tarantula but
i would never hold a tarantula in your
hand like in fifth grade they never said
hey hold this tarantula or some somebody
bring that what about a big snake like
from slavery
uh if it was like a snake that wasn't
going to kill me and like people none of
them are going to kill you
snakeskin no no but none of the things
that we brought to you were going to
kill you no but that's what i'm saying
is if the snake didn't wasn't a threat
to my life i wouldn't be super creeped
out by snake i like lizards like i think
we all have our thing oh i have my thing
if i if i see even one when when we were
when i was in hawaii last time i was in
the middle seat um sandwiched between um
my sister that's my worst nightmare more
than a spider
and we uh we're driving back from the
north shore and i look over at the ac
vent right in front of my knee and i see
a cockroach just go inside the ac vent
i almost killed the entire car i freaked
out so hard that i sat on top of my
sister and i was threatening to open
because the car door as it was going
like spray that was coming out of there
the roaches
um do to me
what i think um spiders do to esther
which is like this visceral this need to
just run whether even if it kills me i
just need to get out of that car yeah
well you realize like people do say that
could be a thing
like
a d in your dna that because of like
like a spider could have killed an
ancestor like you know like that's a
real thing well i have one and they say
that like pregnant women are especially
afraid of spiders because spiders have
something that can like harm the baby
like there there is truth to this are
you
telling us that your ancestors were
killed by spiders by the smell of fire
by spiders by the texture of bananas
can i you can't disprove it
can i give you my history on cockroaches
yes the reason that i feel i need to
jump is because my whole life i was
terrorized by cockroaches so in the
philippines we have the aerial ones that
fly
so when i anytime i was walking around
the house or even in asleep they would
jump into my hair and i would have to
crunch it in my hair and then all of its
juices would come down and if they
didn't if i didn't kill them beforehand
my sister and i would wake up and we
would have these holes in our shins
because they were carnivorous
and they would just eat at our shin meat
and when i came to america they promised
me they were there weren't any big
roaches here so i was like oh my god
we've made it america doesn't have now
you're living with one that's so weird
and so our first apartment there were
these tiny little roaches and i was like
oh that's nothing american roaches are
cool but there were thousands of them
and every time i i went to school in my
backpack when i opened a textbook there
just would like like
roaches everywhere and they would tease
me they'd be like oh dang girl like
where do you live you brought roaches to
school i would bring them to swim
practice they were [ __ ] everywhere so
roaches have terrorized my life i had
crabs in college we've all been through
it okay
now i still eat them by the way
everybody was two hundred dollars she
gave me everyone's been wondering oh
yeah and delighted
there's about 20 left oh we had a feast
i have a question is your vagina like is
europe vagina is your vagina like where
is it
no
because
mine's right here do you ever like do
you remember like guys like in the early
days they thought it was like here but
it's like
deep
imagine you're really far back is yours
is like in there right it's between
mine is are you ever surprised by like
how it's far back but what do you mean
surprised like did it move while i was
sleeping i don't know sometimes i'm like
i feel like mine is like really down
there all right pull it out
let's see okay no i want to see like
ours in the same place
here there's here's mine guys i don't
want the hair
oh my god she's touching me right here i
i want to say that
give me your finger
give me it's give me one thing it feels
like the twinkie from last week it's
right here
that's the hole that's a hole yeah
that's really forward will you feel mine
yeah
all of this just so someone can touch
your [ __ ] come here
is it here no that's that's my butt yeah
after it's normal are you sure
i guess no one wants to touch my [ __ ]
mine's
right here let me see okay i think i'm
okay i think all the audio listeners
everybody in the room touched each other
everyone's [ __ ] is in the right place i
didn't touch kaleilas because i wanted
to be really special when i touched hers
for the first time
you don't want me to be later no no
esther is going to be holding the camera
and
there will be pedals on the bed
we'll be placing the pedals but that's
i'm not making that up right like guys
used to think it was like in the front
well i think it's because the the the
placement of the [ __ ] but the [ __ ] is
more in the front and that is the one
they really need to be looking for
um guys pete and george um said that um
since we're having a special goth
episode that i should read you
one of my poems
oh another poem yeah is this a new one
what year was this
these are all teenage poems guys
by the way
i think you should read one an episode
i'll write one
i know you don't like the rhyming ones
so i'll steer clear from the right ones
do everything you want look i like to
rhyme in high school oh my gosh oh my
god we can turn into a rap esther drop a
beat
in district 68 it's time to celebrate
join and participate i said schools are
great there's not a nerdier
rap of all time
this one is called the unfeeling
oh my god
esther are you paying attention okay no
it's better i'm already so bored
i don't want to hear the poem i'm just
being honest like my makeup matches this
poem
please look me in the eye when i'm
reading this annie i'm putting my
necklace on for even in the liveliest
corner
on the brightest hour of the year
when my pockets are fullest
the sun is at its highest the breeze is
at its gentlest and the untroubled croon
of my friend's laughter envelops the
mood and sits against a backdrop of a
joyous enormity
i am defunct i am dead
oh i i like the message
make like a dead person and never write
another poem the messages
you can make like a corpse and not be
able to use your fingers anymore that
would be great is is the message like
even though life is happening
and all these things around me are going
seemingly good i'm it doesn't matter i'm
still dead inside i'm depressed oh my
god of course you like that
oh my god i think it was beautiful thank
you
can i buy it off of you
yes a hundred thousand dollars i think i
try to kill myself three days later i
know you're like left you're like i sent
this bomb out to everyone why did no one
come to my house what is that thing um
george when you um like the antique road
show when there's a story behind it uh
provenance no see that's the provenance
of course the provenance of the poem is
that three days later i try to kill
myself guys so if you want to purchase
the poem let me know nft is coming soon
yes nf
please don't write that again please no
no it was good i liked it i appreciate
your poetry i love a good teen poet too
because it's there's so much in it
there's so much heart we're so much more
emotional and dramatic when we're teens
it's really weird well as someone that's
never grown out of your teen years
it's weird
no i really infantilize you i don't know
if that's the word i infantilize
infantilize you
yeah of course there's a fantasy
involved
um
i wish that you would i walked you to
your car like i do not look at you as
someone that's able to like oh i know
and i cross the street without holding a
grown-up's hand and looking both ways i
recognize that you do it and i do not
stop you
i fully am like yeah no you should walk
now i'm like teeny minute i'm like i'm
carrying her i'm like come on esther it
really is your instinct and i just i
didn't want you to notice that it was
happening because i wanted it to keep
happening
oh
i okay i just heard a philosophy that
we're already dead and if you just
assume you're already dead how your life
could be more free
and good well that sends me somehow into
a panic
i feel like our friend jenna has a
tattoo doesn't it say like
you'll be dead
something you're going to be dead yeah a
little if you're reading this it's like
this ring
jenna you [ __ ]
but seven days later i feel like it's a
similar thing of
okay so let's say you're afraid to do
something whatever you're going to be
dead soon anyway so why not just do the
ask the person out or you know whatever
it is that you're so scared of well
you're going to die teenage for that to
be the thing for you
it's a problem well is there something
that you
are scared to do but if you tell
yourself i'm going to be dead one day
like i'll do i'll just do it yeah when i
let you touch me
i'm not really afraid of many things but
i think because i do kind of live that
way i'm afraid of many things
a lot more than it would seem i'm a lot
less afraid now that i'm on lexapro yeah
i think i'm going to get on that level
yesterday
last week in therapy she was like it's
time
really it is she yeah i'm gonna i'm
seeing a psychiatrist in in september
because i think that her thing was how
many days out of the year are you
willing to suffer
and i said
you know she's like the last couple
years of your life she's like how many
days are you willing to give to that
suffering i'm like okay touche [ __ ] i
have a i have an alternative option to
pose for both of you
now get on your alexa pro and enjoy it
for a little while okay and then i'm not
on it yet and then
in
five weeks i don't know how long it is
wait are you gonna get certified
certified no to be a hypnotist no way
yes hypno motivation
hypnotic recollections i don't know what
any of these are yet i just got the box
oh please let me be your guinea pig i'm
to guinea pig the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
both of you guys now this is an issue
it's dvds i have to hypnotize it do you
i have to hypnotize my computer into
having a dvd player
there it is
i thought these weren't real
oh it's like a change it's one of the
things yeah
oh you are getting taller
[Laughter]
wow i'm so excited
i'm taking like eight hour classes like
are you serious and why do you want
because
you can't hypnotize yourself right no i
mean maybe you can i don't know it's
just you're just not i just okay so i've
been talking a lot about yeah i guess
you can hypnotize yourself but i've been
hypnosis has like really helped me so
much and so many people are coming up to
me after shows and stuff
and they're like really interested in it
and stuff and i want to like i think
there's just something i can do with it
that's like melding what i do which is
being funny
and hypnosis somehow and like i just i
don't know i just have a vision of some
things i think like how could it hurt if
i learn it but it's really helped me so
much it's been so cool i'm telling you i
don't have
my jaw is not tense anymore oh wait can
i make fun of your tick-tock real quick
fine
you're so dirty that you wore gloves to
go into your own mouth
that's not why it's because the gloves
make it feel better
more like a can i i will if we ever put
my hands in your mouth right now
manipulating for your tmj pain yes
esther do my tmj because it's still sore
but it's like i'm telling you i'm not
like the clunky well let's see if this
is
so i did a tick tock showing how i go
into my own mouth i was just like i
wonder like a shoe is she do you think
your mouth is dirty or your hand i
couldn't tell
okay yes okay esther is hovering above
annie she is right about she's using her
right and hand she's moving to the left
side of annie now
and she is sticking her left thumb into
the right side of the annie's jaw thumbs
do not go far enough back commit to it
essentially all the way
are your fingers too little i'm not
gonna bite you think i'm gonna chomp
down no
if it was your deck i would
she's re-entering annie's mouth is this
what you're trying to manipulate the
masseter muscle
how does it feel annie
is is it getting there okay and he's
giving me the thumbs up
seems like she's really getting that
masseter muscle finally
did i do anything like how how did i do
it was good i mean it was light you were
more scared than me which i feel like is
not usually the practice
i don't i'm not usually the one coaching
the massage massage therapist into it
imagine as a nurse how did i do
asking her patients i mean esther's
actually going to nursing school's one
i'm like i've never wanted to dare
someone to do something more yes esther
to nursing school she goes kyla how did
i do
from where i was standing it seemed as
though at first you were a little
hesitant i wanted to be gentle you know
i'm go it's very pr i'm violating her i
didn't want her i wanted her to feel
strongly wide open i was yeah
my jaw was behind my ears let's just say
that okay what would you hypnotize me
and kalila for
oh my god you
i i don't know yet but it'll be [ __ ]
up let's just say you'll be eating
spiders
let's just say you'll be
with a [ __ ] smile on your face
she's gonna be like someone put a fire i
wanted to smell smoke
do you want to call your mummy okay so
i'm on my podcast mama and i wanted to i
was telling them that i got to the
bottom of why
you were telling my sister-in-laws i was
infertile so i asked you on vacation i
said mom why did you tell people that i
couldn't have kids you want me to really
tell the truth say exactly say the exact
truth because you had so much sex and
never got pregnant
mrs mrs annie letterman how do you know
that annie had so much sex could she
tell me
is that was it weird for her to tell you
that all right all right i'll tell you a
story
annie will not be embarrassed by this
story i promise i'm i'm filling with
blood she invited me to brooklyn to help
her move i think
or clean up her apartment or something
it was the first apartment you had in
brooklyn it was my third apartment but
yes i did i brought you just to help me
clean it well i wasn't even moving i was
just like oh my room's messy mom come
clean it all right okay i know you're
into it
where you live there's two guys right
yep act mike racine and dancing
so i slept in your
double bed with you and i had to get up
and go to the bathroom in the middle of
the night and i
slipped on some lube
she slept on astroglide
are you serious
i have a picture of her cleaning up
astroglide on my floor i'll find it
all right well i'm gonna go i love you
does anyone have any more questions
i mean
millions
now's your chance what do you think of
of her wild childness
don't ruin myself he's always been very
convinced very very conventional
mom you've sent me some really sweet
some really sweet texts recently you're
very proud of me
oh yeah
really yeah it's really like i'm really
i'm getting everything i want in life
it's very weird
like my mom sending me texts like their
dream text what do you have in your eyes
i have um contacts but i dropped them in
both in the toilet
so i think i'm gonna get pink eye but
it's worth it
yeah it's worth it
it's a podcast it's worth it to get to
get eye infection wait mom how about
remember when i was like uh you were
like podcasts are so boring and i was
like oh my god what podcast do you
listen to what was your answer
i don't remember you said i've only
listened to yours
wow you should do rose battle
um all right i love you mommy all right
all right i'll call you later bye bye
the only one that exclusively talks [ __ ]
on you so you
it's the better one i've watched but i
do like it
i know she was talking about my solo
before all right i love you
my mama hi mrs annie
i would love to do like a full-blown
sit-down interview with your mom i think
we should do that with all of our
we should have your mom your mom and my
mom on these chairs so just replace us
for an episode oh
that my mom would be so nervous about
that my mom too she was freezing
because all of our moms i think pretend
to be nervous my mom's not into
entertainment your guys moms are like
are fans of entertainment yeah but my
mom my whole family just wants attention
i brought my brother up i did caroline's
by the way everyone that came out to the
shows like it's amazing like when you go
back on the it's you're gonna see it's
like
it's a whole it's a special thing like
i'm so glad we're resonating with you
guys it's like [ __ ] wow it's such an
honor to perform for the sluggies it's
like unbelievable it's really something
going on but
um you brought your brother my brother
was my older brother was there and i
just knew he was going to heckle so once
he started talking i was like do you
want to do stand up and he went well
okay and then came up immediately and
then tried to do a set and was like are
you still laughing at me i'm like yeah
it's really hard to do it for a really
long time
wow i can't believe he was like yeah
yeah my whole family is yell come up max
like sticks in the back but he wants to
come up wow
oh my god
my mom would be on a plane back
you know who i would have in place of my
mom is bobby's mom oh
she is a personality she should have
i've never been a show i would love ryan
genie genie's a [ __ ]
is a good he's the best
what's your mother's name mary tess
meritas yeah does she does she watch our
show because my mom watches annie's mom
watches yeah really yeah
she watches it and so does my stepdad
now you want to hear a text that i um
got from him yeah this will make you
feel good
which is like the weirdest thing because
my whole life he's always been like
you really are um what a waste of a good
brain is what he's always told me my
whole whoa
but you know roger has his feelings he's
always like you just you could have been
a scientist he could have been this it's
not it's actually complimentary yeah it
is it is we really like take things yeah
he's probably not wrong he said i am
very pleased with you
i wasn't sure at first but you've really
found your ni your niche now
i always liked your independence but now
i'm even more impressed i love you wench
wench that's so cute can i redo my mom's
nice yeah i wanted to ask about that
okay so she goes i forgot to tell you
when i was trolling you on the internet
i listened to a podcast you did
at the beginning of kovid
and i have to tell you you are
absolutely hilarious i couldn't stop
laughing except to cough and blow my
nose oh my gosh i'm so proud of you and
what you've accomplished sweetheart it's
all you no one else oh
oh andy
this is like our progress is good you
guys we're finally getting our parents
approval though for real like for the
first time actually tiger belly didn't
do that for me i mean i've always had
your parents approval
do you remember the night my mom came to
our show this is amazing you guys my mom
came to watch me and five five my
friends who stand up and when asked who
her favorite one was she said annie
and i was like are you sure i was so
good it really was very funny i was on
that night that's really your answer
like i was shocked my set was half your
set dude though then you were you were
part of my set yeah that was really fun
that was it was the night that we've all
it was right a few days after we all
found out brodie passed away and so it
was that day
it might have been and we were just like
we can't do this and then we're like
let's just do it so we're all together
my mom was in town and yeah it was it
was it ended up i mean i rambled on
stage and i don't know what i said but
it was really good but it was
anyways my mom discovered her favorite
comedian
so that's cool i've always had with
parents that have trouble like being
vulnerable with their children they
always like go through me i'm like the
conduit i don't think that's what this
is but thank you
thank you so i want to end on a positive
note since we we had some highs and lows
some peaks um what a ride i hope this
whole podcast is edited out and this is
five minute episode it's a five minute
episode it's just esther walking in
for five minutes
versus slow motion whatever was left
it's just you fingering both of us
it has the juiciest
i want to say that we've been doing this
now for what like six months
and
dare i say i've never been prouder
of
something
that
i've even taken part of like you know we
were just
three friends on facetime saying hey why
don't we do this and not only did we do
it we followed through
and we still have a good time doing this
we're so silly
and we made we made a thing guys and i'm
really proud of you guys and i love you
a lot and i hope we get to do this for a
very long time yeah i'm gonna cry like
because i do feel like i'm so annoying
and i'm like do you hate me now
after no one hates me i just took myself
out of the group chat and it works
perfect
it's literally all i needed to do
like i feel the same way but you guys
know i'm like such a sucker for like
girls hanging out and like making money
in business and like speaking your truth
and owning your like
like like what you said like you shout
out about being molested and like the
way that that had that the impact that
has on other people
like that's not just you with the belt
[Laughter]
i don't know i really know how to beat a
raped horse don't i
honestly that might be my favorite thing
about the three of us that i think we
all have in common is
is
being confident about our [ __ ] up
lives and our flaws and like
sharing that so that if someone else
feels that way too they don't have to
feel so bad if they have nipple hair or
if they're nervous that their vagina is
a little further back than it should be
honestly if you don't have nipple hair
you should feel ashamed of yourself
and i recently met a bartender at a
rooftop hotel who was like oh i love
your i love your show and i was like oh
of course it's tiger belly this guy is
like super yolked he's bald he's like a
break dancer and he was like no i love
uh trashes and
i was like thank you so much now it's
fun to tell boys about diarrhea and
stuff it's like fun for them to know
it's good to just be ourselves in front
of people i love that we have like boy
slugs yeah yeah so with that said no
matter what our name is it doesn't
matter it's the three of us and we're
gonna have fun doing this for a very
long time to come so
go [ __ ] yourself
is this a weird time to tell you guys i
quit
i can't stand you i hate the show anyway
i gotta go
i'm joining bloodbath they need it we
love you guys so much we'll see you next
week bye cry
my eyes are going to be sealed shut up
wow am i going to keep yourself
your eyes
[Music]
you